je sais ce que c'est que de me mettre en
colère
et je connais le plaisir d'être loué
je suis souvent au bord des larmes ou du
rire
mais au-delà de ses émotions
qui a-t-il donc
comment puis-je toucher cela
et s'il n'y a rien
pourquoi suis-je si certains qu'il y a
quelque chose
peut-on jouer avec la baguette en
rubanée comme ça
chaque baguette produit un son différent
essaye pour voir
on devrait peut-être enlever du tissu
sur l'autre
[Musique]
me débarrassant de mes cheveux en me
débarrassant de mes cheveux je prononce
aujourd'hui les vœux je prononce
aujourd'hui les vœux de transformer
toutes mes afflictions de transformer
toutes mes afflictions et devenir en
aide à tous les êtres vivants et de
venir en aide à tous les êtres vivants
[Musique]
quand arrive l'hiver glacé
il est sans pitié pour tout ce qui est
jeune tendre et mal à fermer
pour survivre il faut dépasser
l'incertitude de la jeunesse
la maturité
et la détermination sont nécessaires
voir à quel point les arbres se
préparent à l'hiver d'une façon sage et
courageuse
cela m'aide à apprécier les leçons que
j'ai apprises
les fleurs symboles de l'éveil
ont la chance alors de continuer à
pousser
il faut lui compose
pour avoir des fleurs
il faut des infections
pour les
addictions sont
le compost
l'aliment de l'éveil
il faut trouver l'éveil même dans les
affections
c'est pourquoi nous avons
l'expression
les afflictions
sont les
trouver le nirvana
dans les naissances et les morts
[Musique]
voici le premier précepte
les rapports sexuels sont interdits si
une chique chamana a des rapports
sexuels elle devra cesser d'être une
chique chamane elle perdra le nom de
fille du Bouddha
elle n'a pas eu de rapport sexuel mais
qu'elle a touché un autre corps en
éprouvant du désir elle restera nonne
n'ayant frein les préceptes des
chichamana
elle devra se confesser et réaffirmer
ses vœux
ceci est le premier des six préceptes
des chiques chamana
acceptez-vous ces préceptes
[Applaudissements]
en écoutant le dharma dans la dimension
ultime
je vois tomber les feuilles d'automne
en plissant tout le ciel
je vois la lune d'automne
sur les chemins ancestraux
ni vide
et l'ermite lui il dort ici
j'ai d'abord pensé qu'il s'agissait d'un
nuage furtif
mais après plusieurs heures
j'ai senti que mon corps partait en
fumée
qu'il s'en allait à voler
je suis devenu une fine volute de nuages
je m'étais toujours considéré comme une
entité solide
et soudain
je réalisais que je ne l'étais
aucunement
j'ai compris que l'entité que j'avais
prise pour moi était en réalité une
fabrication
ma vraie nature je le réalisais
était beaucoup plus réel
à la fois plus laide et plus belle que
je ne l'avais imaginé
[Musique]
j'ai demandé à sœur Kamen Guilhem si
elle était heureuse l'autre jour
heureuse a-t-elle répondu c'est
difficile à dire
puis je lui ai demandé si elle était
comment dire satisfaite
et elle a dit oui
elle a dit oui
je passe beaucoup de temps à cuisiner
c'est très agréable
mais quand je dois faire autre chose je
manque d'inspiration
c'est peut-être différent pour les
autres
mais si je dois faire la même chose trop
longtemps il m'arrive de ressentir de la
lassitude
quand c'est ta responsabilité c'est un
plaisir de l'accomplir
mais les tâches répétitives menaces
c'est vrai
par amour pour notre maître cela m'aide
à surmonter la monotonie
mais parfois j'ai besoin de m'échapper
pour mes revenus et être plus disponible
pour lui
entre nous on peut parler de tout mais
sans jamais se lamenter
vous les novices pouvez-vous éloigner
ces différents pour nous avec le temps
ce besoin s'amenuise
tu es prêt tu es doué
voilà
on place la serviette à droite
les amis souhaitent que vous leur
appréciez sous la forme qu'ils
connaissent
mais cela n'est pas possible
comment pourrions-nous continuer à vivre
si nous restions et
pour vivre
nous devons mourir à chaque instant
périr toujours et sans cesse
et ce sont les orages qui permettent le
déroulement de la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
j'étais devenu un champ de bataille
je n'avais aucun moyen de savoir si
j'allais survivre
non en ce qui concerne et mon existence
physique
mais dans le sens plus profond du noyau
de mon être
je vivais destruction sur destruction
et je ressentais l'art dans désir d'être
avec ceux que j'aimais
tout en sachant que s'ils avaient été
présents
il m'aurait fallu les chasser
ou les fuir
j'ai sorti 500 euros OK
ou alors on commence par une semaine peu
importe aucun souci on pourra faire la
pointe par la suite une semaine alors on
retrouve d'autres enfants
donc si on comme c'était prévu si on
vous met dans le groupe des jeunes
adultes c'est des adultes célibataires
donc bon
[Musique]
alors là il se trouve que c'est une
pendule ça l'étage mais en fait d'une
manière générale au village à chaque
fois qu'on entend une place
on se met à n'importe quelle sonnerie on
s'arrête pour essayer de relier au
moment présent on en est ce qu'on
appelle le pilotage automatique tout le
temps donc l'idée c'est de décrocher ça
c'est difficile ça demande beaucoup
d'entraînement mais voilà on s'entraîne
ensemble
[Musique]
j'avais un chien
il est mort j'ai été très triste
alors je ne sais pas comment arrêter
d'être triste
des avait
difficile
là-haut dans le ciel tu vois un
magnifique nuage
tu aimes énormément ce nuage
quand soudainement
passé mon cher nuage
si tu prends le temps de réfléchir de
regarder
tu vois que le nuage n'est pas mort qui
ne s'est pas éteint
le nuage est devenu la pluie et quand tu
regardes la pluie tu vois ton nuage et
quand tu bois ton thé on y prétend
attention tu peux voir la pluie dans ton
thé
tu vois ton nuage et tu peux dire
bonjour mon nuage je sais que tu n'es
pas mort tu es en vie sous une nouvelle
forme c'est la même chose pour ton petit
chien
si tu regardes profondément tu verras
ton petit chien sous sa nouvelle forme
quand l'orage se fut finalement
s'éloigner
des couches de ciment intérieures
étaient effondrées
sur le champ de bataille maintenant
désert
quelques rayons de soleil éclairaient
l'horizon
trop faible encore pour apporter de la
chaleur à mon âme épuisée
j'étais couvert de blessures
et pourtant j'ai trouvé un sentiment
presque poignant de solitude
personne n'allait plus me reconnaître
dans ma nouvelle façon d'être
personne dans mon entourage ne saurait
que c'était moi
[Musique]
tu m'as apporté
tellement de bonheur
quand ton père est parti
c'est toi qui m'a donné l'énergie de
travailler et continuer à vivre
je sais que tout est arrivé par ma faute
j'ai beaucoup de pression au travail
je rentre tard et je n'ai pas le temps
de me poser je n'y parviens pas et c'est
pour ça que je m'emporte sur toi mon
fils
je te promets de faire mieux
je vais respirer comme nous l'a enseigné
je tenais à te dire
que maman t'aime énormément
j'apprécie mon inspiration
j'expire
je libère l'air expiré
à
[Musique]
mais ça c'est une chanson
que nous aimons chanter au Village des
Pruniers
je suis arrivé je suis chez moi
c'est une chanson de pratique
de la pleine conscience et de toujours
arriver
ici et maintenant
nous avons beaucoup couru
mais nous ne sommes pas arrivés
nous sommes sans cesse à chercher à
fouiller désireux de trouver quelque
chose
mais nous n'avons pas trouvé
alors nous continuons notre course
il reste à parcourir dans cette quête
de bonheur que nous pensons ne pas avoir
courir et chercher et devenu une
habitude
alors que la vie et les merveilles qui
l'accompagnent
ne sont disponibles que dans le moment
présent
parce que le passé n'est plus
l'avenir n'existe pas encore il n'y a
que le moment présent
donc la pratique de la pleine conscience
nous aide
à nous sentir chez nous dans l'ici et le
maintenant
afin d'apprendre à vivre profondément
pour ne pas gaspiller notre vie
[Musique]
[Rires]
les montagnes et les rivières
la Terre et le Soleil
tout cela repose dans le cœur de la
conscience
lorsqu'on réalise enfin cela
le temps et l'espace disparaissent
la cause et l'effet la naissance la mort
tout se disciple
même si j'habite à 100.000
années-lumière d'une étoile
je peux traverser cette distance en un
éclair
[Musique]
laissez le maître du thé servir l'État
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
selon la parole de Dieu
Bouddha ne peut pas vous sauver Mahomet
ne peut pas vous sauver Krishna ne peut
pas vous sauver Charles Darwin ne peut
pas vous sauver et vous ne pouvez pas
vous sauver vous-même je ne peux pas me
sauver moi-même
tu crains les autres pourquoi craindre
Satan existe Dieu existe
si vous n'êtes pas aux côtés du Dieu
Jéhovah si vous n'êtes pas avec
Jésus-Christ
vous êtes contre lui ce ne sont pas mes
parents mais les siennes
pourquoi suivre la voie sans issue de
Bouddha quand vous pouvez croire en
Jésus et connaître la vie éternelle
aucune preuve de ça mec Jésus l'a dit il
a aussi dit aime ton prochain et
présente l'autre jour
pourquoi vous m'ignorez
donc mes paroles vous effraient
tellement que vous refusez le dialogue
[Musique]
vous vous énervez
c'est vous qui vous énervez monsieur
regardez vous rabaissez les bouddhistes
vous êtes le seul ici à l'érabaisser
personne ne rabaisse personne vous êtes
le seul à porter un jugement Jésus
prenait l'amour pas le jugement
marcher un peu plus vite
presque normalement
on accélère un peu
[Musique]
puis très très vite allez très très vite
prenez conscience de vos pieds en
marchant
et maintenant on s'arrête on s'arrête
avez-vous déjà vu des moines ou des non
oui au cinéma au cinéma
communes
il y a quatre personnes par chambre
au début il n'y avait presque rien dans
notre monastère
il n'y avait pas de lit car nous
n'avions pas d'argent
nous faisons vœu de ne pas avoir de
possession
nous n'avons ni argent ni banque ni
carte de crédit
nous n'avons pas de voiture personnelle
téléphone portable téléphone portable on
n'a pas de on n'a pas d'argent du tout
on a de l'argent de poche mais à peine
environ 40 dollars par mois non ce n'est
pas beaucoup
[Rires]
quand vous avez une maison une voiture
et toutes ses possessions elles sont
source d'inquiétude
ce n'est pas uniquement
quelque chose va vous rendre heureux
et en fait vous n'êtes pas heureux
et si vous brisez une de vos règles il
existe différents types de règles
disons si vous avez une petite amie ou
que vous vous mettez à fumer alors vous
n'êtes plus moine
vous êtes célibataire marié nous sommes
célibataires pas mariés car nous avons
fait le choix d'une vie qui exclut le
sexe ou la notion de partenaire ou de
tout autre personne oui oui nous sommes
très heureux ainsi
il fallait que je vérifie
le
contrôler il n'y a pas de maître nous
avons un professeur un professeur pour
moi c'est un maître certaines personnes
disent maître car il est très un peu
comme vous voyez Yoda dans Star Wars il
est un peu comme lui
je veux perdre personne on est prêt je
peux faire personne
[Musique]
avec moi
on est presque juste beaucoup mieux ok
presque juste
[Musique]
je suis très tôt que trouver la vérité
n'est pas trouvé le bonheur
vous aspirez avoir la vérité
mais une fois que vous l'avez vu
cela ne vous empêche pas de souffrir
si l'on va autrement
ce que vous n'avez rien vu
[Musique]
je peux venir ici que tous les deux ans
parce que je vis en France dans un
monastère alors je peux venir rendre
visite à mon père et à ma famille aux
États-Unis que tous les deux ans mais je
me sens très chanceuse parce que mes
frères et sœurs du monastère peuvent pas
avoir leur famille aussi souvent
à gauche sur votre gauche
bonjour papounet c'est pas vrai
il pleure il pleure toujours quand il
est heureux
béni soit tu mon dieu merci
tu peux te reposer sur moi maintenant
Seigneur
ça fait longtemps qu'on s'est pas vu
surprise on dirait que tu as 19 ans mais
j'ai 19 ans j'ai 19 ans
tu t'es rasé la tête
je me rase tout comme toi tu traces tu
me rase toutes les deux trois semaines
ah bon c'est bien c'est bien tu sais je
fais ça aussi une fois par an
voyons voir tes cheveux
j'ai froid la tête maintenant
ça te va bien vraiment
pour te redresse un peu
j'ai tout ratatiner
ta main c'est vrai c'est vrai regarde ce
que j'ai pour toi
alors respirer reconnecte avec ton corps
inspire
et expire avec beaucoup de gratitude
inspire et expire avec joie
ça va
[Musique]
sortir toute cette joie qui a été
coincée depuis combien d'années
laisse la sortir
souvent quand je viens une esquisse même
pas un sourire
expire en relâchant toute cette tension
inspire
à chaque fois que tu te sens bouleversé
ça fait du bien
merci Seigneur
tu peux dire merci Seigneur
nous aussi on a de la chance que tu sois
encore avec nous
est-ce que c'est un moment heureux ou
pas le bonheur
ici et maintenant qui dès qu'on doit
aller ailleurs
le paradis c'est juste ici
juste là
avec nous tous avec nous tous béni soit
le Seigneur et elles sont sur leur
portable
[Rires]
oui je sais tu peux nous passer un
mouchoir s'il te plaît
il me faut une prise voilà
bon sang
c'est bon
alors vous transférer
travaillez-vous aussi dur chez vous
je suis retraité
on travaille moins dur
alors c'est comme ça que vous travaillez
avant
on peut dire ça oui on aurait dit vous
inviter à chanter avec nous quand vous
êtes arrivés le chant parle du travail
le voici
on va vous ralentir
vous savez vous me rappelez quelqu'un
j'ignore pourquoi vous êtes de saint
Paul Minneapolis
c'était quoi votre nom avant quand
j'étais prêtre c'était père Adrian
c'était
ensuite Adrian mort
croyez-moi
alors
tu es un vrai miracle tu as l'air en
forme
dernière nouvelle tu étais très malade
puis plus rien il y a 20 ans j'ai eu un
cancer
j'ai suivi une chimio très lourde
à cette époque que j'ai adhéré à ce
projet d'accord pendant une séance de
chimio j'ai lu un livre emprunté à ma
compagne le miracle de la pleine
conscience
c'est incroyable nous avons travaillé
ensemble
au tribunal
avec des criminels
quelque chose de familier je le connais
mais
[Rires]
contente de te voir
c'est formidable
on se reverra dans la semaine d'accord
très bien
je voudrais vous poser une question je
travaille pour une association de
thérapie acoustique ma question est la
suivante si le silence mène à la pleine
conscience
et à l'éveil
quel est l'objet du son
et qu'est-ce que le son sacré
tout comme le noir absorbe les autres
couleurs
le silence peut absorber tous les sons
c'est un son remarquable ne sent sacré
dans notre pratique nous recherchons le
profond silence intérieur
dans l'esprit les perceptions les
pensées
la tranquillité du corps
à partir de laquelle d'autres sons
peuvent être
si nous résidons dans le chaos ou dans
le mouvement
nous ne percevons que du bruit
alors comment définissez-vous le son
sacré que signifie l'expression son
sacrées existe-t-il un son sacré si tant
est qu'il existe comme je vous le disais
quand vous faites un pas en harmonie
avec la Terre Mère et que vous ne sentez
pas de division entre vous-même la
Terre-Mère la nature et tout ce qui vit
vous entendez à son profond
il est sans limite
de ce son peut éclater une chanson un
poème un sourire
peut-être un son merveilleux
[Musique]
c'est bon de te voir maman
alors c'est une curieuse maison
jardin est toujours là
le jardin
oui
il n'y a pas grand chose en ce moment
mais toutes les plantes vont sortir
d'ici un mois
regarde
oh oui
regarde c'est incroyable c'est mon
journal intime
regarde ici il y a plein de dessins
c'est incroyable tu trouves pas
mon dieu
c'est vraiment très détaillé
naissance
7 ans avoir des amis être cool
faire du théâtre et exceller dans tous
les sports
[Musique]
par an
26 ans se marier acheter une maison à un
million de dollars
par un super content
quarantaine avant tout ce qu'il faut
carrière sur les rails
devenir directeur général de ma société
tout le monde nage dans le bonheur
70 ans
comment vas-tu y arriver c'est une vie
bien remplie
[Musique]
ce n'est pas nécessaire non
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci merci
beaucoup avec plaisir
avec apprécié bonne journée
c'était vraiment extra
je n'ai pas fait ça depuis plus de 60
ans c'est vrai
bonne journée
[Musique]
c'est magnifique regardez ça il y a même
des petits
à ce moment je me suis senti
parfaitement en paix
sans que la moindre anxiété est pénétrée
dans mon esprit
les idées du passé du présent et du
futur c'était evanoui
et je me tenais sur le seuil lumineux
d'une réalité
qui transcendait le temps
l'espace et l'action
je me suis levé
et je suis resté en méditation le reste
de la nuit
il ne restait plus qu'une paix
profondément enracinée
j'étais assis comme une montagne
et je souriais
[Musique]